lassen sie uns über die warnungen
sprechen die es vorher gab vor dieser
katastrophe wann hatten sie auf ihrem
schreibtisch die erste warnung die
gesagt hat da kommt eine absolute
extremwetter situation auf sie zu ich
kann es nicht mehr genau wann ich glaube
es war anfang der woche da waren wir
über den wetterdienst informiert das ist
ja dann auch automatisch weitergereicht
worden anderen zuständigen behörden
also gewusst hat jeder das da war sowohl
zukommt wahrheit ist allerdings auch
dass man immer das immer schwerer wird
genau zu sagen wo wird die große menge
geld was darunter fallen also man hat
ein gefühl dafür in welchem region aber
das ist manchmal sehr eingegrenzt und
bei uns im bundesland war das auch noch
unterschiedlich auch total anders also
in arbeiter wir hatten die größten
probleme gerade in den mittelstädten bei
der kleinen flüsse das wasser nicht
gehalten haben und das kam nicht nur
durch starkregen sondern es kam dadurch
dass in den talsperren zu viel wasser
schon war und dafür noch viel drauf
haben und die das nicht gehalten haben
und dann musste wasser abgelassen werden
und das führt zum beispiel hier in
meiner stadt ist super fließt hier durch
da war alles voll und die das war auch
dramatisch aber als dann die flutwelle
kamen da wackelt die ganze stadt unter
wasser und er nun aus vor allen dingen
das kommt dann ganz plötzlich das hätte
anders kommen können also ich bin immer
ich bin solange er seine politik dass
ich einfach keine lust mehr braucht all
die schlaumeier die alle schon wussten
es ist leider ihre kompliziert und so
was hat weil der wupper zum beispiel
seit 100 jahren nicht gegeben
es soll keine entschuldigung sein
sondern es ist einfach mal fakt und wir
werden natürlich nachzudenken haben wie
können wir waren systeme noch verbessern
eine frage wie können wir auch die
menschen die jetzt keine nina app haben
trotzdem erreichen
es gibt glaube ich nicht um schlaumeier
domherr all das muss ganz klar gesagt
werden und im nachhinein ist man
natürlich schlauer die frage ist was man
vorher wusste und was aus warnungen
geworden ist also vor allen dingen
internationale medien berichten ja heute
unter anderem der guardian oder die
sunday times wir können das auch mal
kurz zeigen es waren alle warnungen
und letztlich sind die aber nicht ernst
genug genommen wurden oder die
warnsysteme sind eben nicht aktiviert
worden
auch bei ihnen sollen diese meldung
geben am wochenende bereits davor
angekommen seien am samstag die sollen
konkretisiert worden seien am montag
nochmal auch durch den deutschen
wetterdienst und dann haben sie gerade
gesagt das ist dann weitergereicht
worden ist das vielleicht das problem
man hat daraus halt nicht direkt eine
handlung entwickelt passt mal auf so
einfach kann man das jetzt auch nicht
machen dann muss ich doch mal
widersprechen
wir sitzen ja nicht fröhlich roman haben
langeweile sondern wir nehmen das ernst
und erreichen das nicht weit das habe
ich gesagt sondern es geht natürlich mit
klaren aufträgen weiter in die struktur
auf regierungspräsidenten kommunen usw
und die sind die letzt verantwortlichen
die dann entscheiden welche art von
warnung wird ausgeworfen
sie sprechen mit einem innenminister der
2018 die sirenen wieder eingeführt hat
ich habe sirenen übungstage gemacht
haben alle gelacht städten knall weil
sie gedacht haben der krieg ist doch
vorbei was will der spinne eigentlich
weil ich begriffen habe dass wir neue
herausforderung gekommen
katastrophenfälle wasser strom brände wo
wir menschen erreichen müssen und diese
idee mit modernen jeder hat doch nina
app ist ja auch nett aber unter uns
gesagt natürlich hat das nicht jeder
eltern menschen haben überhaupt kein
computer oder kein handy und der strobl
st der strom ist ausgefallen
das handy netzes ausgefallen vielerorts
sofort auch das aber ja erst nachher
aber nachher zum teil ist also nicht am
anfang bei der warnung vorneweg
unter uns gesagt gilt das argument nicht
also lina etwa schon ein instrument das
zweite instrument sind sirenen die wir
ausbauen
wir haben darüber wer in 5100 weiß ich
wie sehr ihn mittlerweile hier übrigens
auch im betrieb die probieren wir jedes
jahr gibt da einen wahn tag über das
testen weil ich glaube dass viele
menschen ja nie mehr wissen wenn sondern
sirene läuft was das stört die einen
sagen da bloß rum die anderen sahen
kriege ist doch vorbei
die amtshaftung solcher probleme das ist
nicht nur eine frage an der politik
wir hatten noch heute ihr ministerium um
antworten gebeten bezüglich der warnung
die es vorher gab und ihrem ministerium
hat auch mit dem satz geantwortet wir
zeigen dass morgen auch auf seite 4 im
bild das sei ein ereignis gewesen dass
absehbar war gleichzeitig ein solches
ereignis war abzusehen so lautet der
satz und gleichzeitig sagen sie auch
dass die hilfs oder wahn systeme im
großen und ganzen funktioniert haben
auch die evakuierungen hätte es nicht
mehr geben sollen das heißt wo ist genau
jetzt der fehler im system wenn wir über
150 über 150 tote insgesamt sprechen den
nordrhein westfalen und rheinland pfalz
ja ich kann den nur über 46 in
nordbayern reden und die sind ganz
unterschiedliche situationen es gab
situationen wo menschen nicht darauf
geachtet haben
es gab situationen wo feuerwehrleute im
einsatz gestorben sind
da hilft auch keine warnung um ein
beispiel zu nennen und es gab
situationen wo sie nicht rechtzeitig wo
sie die sorgen auch nicht ernst genommen
haben ich kann der frau bürgermeisterin
ja nur zustimmen ich glaube ganz viele
menschen haben die gefahren die da
entstehen sind auch noch nicht so
richtig verinnerlicht hallo ich glaube
da ist übrigens auch eine riesenaufgabe
aufklärerisch tätig zu sein klingt jetzt
so banal aber es ist nicht ganz
unwichtig ich habe ganz viele leute
jetzt erlebt die sagen das hätte ich mir
gar nicht vorstellen können als ich da
stand und das wasserniveau basar
sowas gibt es darüber auch nicht doch
das gibt es und das kann es noch mal
geben
ja genau deshalb muss man wenn
staatliche institutionen hinweise geben
warnungen aussprechen sirenen anstellen
oder feuerwehrleute mit dem
feuerwehrwagen durch die städte fahren
mit lautsprechern dann muss man auch
bereit sein sich darauf einzulassen aber
es ist glaube ich zu früh das
abschließend zu bewerten aber die
vorläufige bilanz ist jetzt wenn ich sie
richtig verstanden habe im großen und
ganzen hat eigentlich alles funktioniert
da würde ich niemals sagen dann wir
jetzt keine 110 toten geben dürfen
es kann nicht alles hundertprozentig
funktioniert haben aber es hat nicht so
schlecht als es gab nach meinem heutigen
der kenntnisstand noch keine großen
grundsätzlichen probleme
aber es gab garantiert auch in
einzelfällen sachen die kann man aber
jetzt nicht beurteilen sie muss man
sieht man erst wenn man jedenfalls ich
genau anschaut und das werden wir machen
das werden wir machen müssen weil man
aus fehlern ja auch lernen muss
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren